otro foco de erupción abre nuevos
caminos al incesante flujo de lava unos
400 metros al norte del foco principal
ahora el cumbre vieja emite dos nuevas
coladas de magma que avanzan en
dirección oeste consumiendo más
edificaciones y generando temores de más
destrucción en la palma
qué es impotencia miedo y lumbre es
miedo y seguridad que te afecta a tu
salud
que no sabe qué va a pasar porque todo a
todos nos ha cogido esto por sorpresa
muy mal porque se nos viene encima una
desgracia impresionante porque esto es
hoy que están aquí todas las cámaras en
medio de comunicación de todo el mundo
pero la ruina que se nos viene encima es
impresionante o sea los llanos han
amanecido negros que negro nos vamos a
poner nosotros en los próximos años
en total son 80 millones de metros
cúbicos de lava los que el volcán ha
emitido desde el inicio de la crisis
está sigue chocando con el océano por lo
que las autoridades intentan monitorear
la calidad del aire a lo largo de la
costa y aunque los niveles de dióxido de
azufre en el área aumentaron no suponen
una amenaza para la salud sin embargo
residentes de llanos de aridane el
municipio más poblado de la isla han
optado por usar tapabocas y gafas ante
la lluvia de cenizas otros se protegen
con paraguas
sí hombre yo por ejemplo anoche con las
cenizas se me irritaron muchísimo los
ojos me tuve que poner mucho suero y la
piel la piel la noto como que pica mucho
el volcán cumbre vieja entró en erupción
el 19 de septiembre desde entonces ha
dañado más de 1000 inmuebles ha
calcinado más de 700 hectáreas y más de
6000 personas han sido evacuadas el
instituto volcanológico de canarias
prevé que la erupción podría durar entre
24 y 84 días se espera una nueva visita
del presidente del gobierno pedro
sánchez este domingo